هذه قصه رحمه واجبه حكايه ناجين من البشر
ينتظرون ناجين من غير البشر
السيده بيرجول خائفه تنتظر انقاذ روح
عالقه تحت انقاض الحظيره
اليوم توجهت لاطعامها اعتقدت انها قد ماتت
وخاطر بحياتي يوميا للوصول اليها
نجت بيرجان لوحدها بعد انهيار المكان
بالكامل
على مدى احد عشر يوما كانت السيده بيرجيل
تشق طريقها تحت الانقاض لتصل اليها
وبينما يستمرون في ازاله الركام يتمكن
فريق بيطري من حفر نفق وراء المبنى
لم تاكل شيئا اليوم فقد شربت الماء اعتقدت
انها ماتت الان ابلغوني انها حيه
ضمن خطط الاستجابه للكارثه تنتشر فرق
مختصه بانقاذ الحيوانات المنزليه في مناطق
الزلزال
انقذنا حتى اليوم بين خمسين الى 60 حيوانا
ارسلناها الى اضنه للعلاج في مستشفى بيطري
بعد ذلك نعيدهم الى اصحابهم نحن جاهزون
عندما نتلقى اي اتصال من عائلات نتوجه
للموقع ونحاول المساعده
القاط الثروه الحيوانيه مساله مهمه يقولون
لنا لدعم معيشه العائلات في ارياف
المحافظات المنكوبه والتي تعتمد على
الزراعه والثروه الحيوانيه في معيشتها
الا ان العمل لا يقتصر على انقاذ موارد
الحياه فالفرق الميدانيه تعمل على قاعده
انقاذ كل حياه تحت الانقاض
نعود الى بيرجان سحبت من تحت الانقاض
اسال الله ان يرضى عن فرق الانقاب
تنتهي قصتنا بخبر مفرح ليستمر الامل في
انتشال مزيد من الناجين سلام خضر الجزيره